welcome to ee380 this is uh uh April
well it's April 12th
2023 uh and uh our speaker today is Alan
carp who is uh as I was saying earlier
before we turn the recording on uh he's
a uh
password mechanic
and uh recent uh uh admitted security
Guru
um any case salad it's all yours tell us
about your password manager I'm very
interested sure let me get this I'm
going to turn off my video first so all
right um let me get started
um I've attended a bunch of these talks
and I've even given some but to be
completely honest this topic is the
least significant of any of them
on that said it's the one you encounter
the most often
now I expect that the first part of this
quote sums up how you feel about
passwords but do you have any idea who
said it
well everybody says it
and if you have any idea when it was
said
um passwords
um in other words uh we're likely stuck
with passwords for quite a while the
Epica
now
so what's so bad about passwords well as
usual XKCD explains the problem best
passwords are hard for people to
remember and easy for computers to guess
and so what do we do in a situation like
that
well one solution is to write them down
now I'm actually surprised that there's
a market for a product like this but
apparently there is or there was for
writing down your passwords
um but perhaps a better solution is to
use the computer than the form of a
password manager
it's the top recommendation but fewer
than half of people actually use one
now I'd like to get a count out of this
group and I was going to set up a zoom
poll but I quit reading the instructions
after page three they were just getting
too complicated so instead if you would
just put the name of your password
manager in the chat and put none if you
don't use one
and also I'd like to know if you're
happy with the password manager you're
using
and for those of you who put none in the
chat I have just one thing to say shame
on you you really should be using a
password manager
there are plenty to choose from this
list is a just a sample there's dozens
more as you can see some of them are
free others cost a few dollars a month
and you got to be careful because every
once in a while one of them shuts down
now we expect certain things from a
password manager I mean if it isn't easy
to use if it doesn't give you the warm
fuzzies if you can't get your Netflix
password when you're at a friend's house
you're simply not going to use it
nothing else matters
um of course if it gets hacked you're
going to stop using it that's for sure
um but the difficulty using it and lack
of trust are are the main reasons that
people give up
um using a password manager
now one important reason for using one
in the first place is you don't have to
remember a different strong password for
every site
unfortunately many password managers
simply store whatever passwords you
happen to use so they don't help a lot
in that regard
also some websites force you to change
your password on a regular basis I have
a ramp on why that's a bad idea but some
password managers will automate that
process for you
now I've been talking about password
managers but I haven't actually said
what they are
so Malwarebytes says that it's an
application that stores your passwords
the government says it's an app on your
device that stores your passwords
Consumer Report says it's a service that
stores your passwords so it sounds like
there's a consensus a password manager
stores your passwords
that definition raises some questions so
for example where does it store your
passwords on your machine
well then how do you get your passwords
when you're at a friend's house
well that means it probably stores it in
the cloud but who's Cloud I mean I have
a cloud I use dropbox I expect some of
you have a cloud my sister doesn't have
a cloud she wouldn't know what to do
about that
that means your password are probably
stored in the password managers cloud
um and how are they stored well they're
probably stored encrypted although not
every password manager does that
um but then who has the encryption key
if it's them can you trust them not to
use it not to lose it or abuse it and if
it's you what happens if you forget your
master password
and of course it costs them money to
manage those user accounts some of them
have more than a million users managing
that many users costs money and they
have to pay for the cloud resources
and then there's this to worry about
what if they get hacked well last
December I got this notification from
LastPass apparently someone stole their
database
now that revealed some customer data but
there's no evidence that any passwords
were leaked even though your protection
depends solely on the strength of your
master password according to Bruce
Schneider in his blog
and this is the kind of event that leads
people to stop trusting their password
manager
so let's think about a different
approach
instead of storing your passwords let's
calculate them
that means the tool can be free because
there are no user accounts to manage or
external storage to pay for
since the calculation only needs local
data you can even use it even without a
network
but the most important thing is it puts
you in control
you can carry a piece of paper with
everything you need to get your
passwords and it's not great if you lose
that piece of paper but it's nothing
close to the problems you have if you
lost that booklet with all your
passwords in it
now I'm going to start the discussion
with site password with a history lesson
mainly so you can see where I stole the
ideas from
so the story starts in the early 2000s
um I got tired of having to remember all
my passwords and I just learned about
hash functions
I thought maybe that can be the solution
to my problem
I happen to be between projects at HP
Labs so I wrote a little python
application
and what you see here is a screenshot of
a Windows executable that a colleague of
mine wrote other people contributed
other versions one wrote a Java applet
someone else a version for pocket PC
others produce versions for Palm Nokia
the Unix command line a less pass is a
modern version of this application
and that's widely used by the way
um
now a year or so later people from the
HP atala division came to visit came to
see us now taller was a security company
with close ties to the finance industry
that HP had recently bought
and they wanted to show they had
something to deal with phishing attacks
at an upcoming Bank uh banking
conference
and they asked if we could turn the
password calculator into a toolbar for
Internet Explorer remember back in the
day how everybody was producing a pool
bar for Internet Explorer
so I turned to our intern kapin Yi and I
said how long would that take
and he said a couple of weeks and he
sounded really grumpy so after the
meeting I cracked him down and asked him
what was wrong and he said you're
treating me like a code monkey
a ping I said you're an intern a Code
Monkey is exactly what you are and he
didn't seem very happy about that answer
but as you'll see he did quite a job
less than three weeks later we had what
you see here
um
ping did a spectacular job and I learned
later that he always does a spectacular
job the way it works is that green box
there you fill in a nickname for the
site here it's PayPal and your user ID
for the site and the toolbar will
remember them so they show up
automatically when you return to the
site your master password is safely
stored so when you click on that button
you can see where the mouse is pointing
um your username and and password get
filled into the website
and if it's a phishing site well your
settings won't show up and so clicking
the button does nothing
I believe this is probably the first
application that deserves the term
password manager and a lot of the
features that we see today
so the Attalla folks showcase this at
the show this at the conference and it
was very well received especially
because it met the the fisma
two-factor authentication requirement
they've treated one factor as your
master password and the second factor is
a local database holding the nicknames
and your user ID for the site
as a result of that response HP offered
this as an official product
interesting the product was free but
businesses could pay for a version that
put their logo on the button so if Wells
Fargo wanted to distribute to their
customers they could pay HP one dollar
per account and have their logo on the
button
the nice part for them was that their
users then would be clicking the Wells
Fargo logo every time they logged in
anywhere
now in spite of that very nice business
model I don't know if anybody actually
paid
an important point about this is the
Apollo folks were serious security folks
and they felt that this approach was
Secure
um it wasn't long after that that people
began to recognize how vulnerable
Internet Explorer was and started to
migrate to other browsers mainly Firefox
now I didn't really have a choice I had
to choose Chrome because the people who
developed Chrome cited our research and
their academic paper when they published
it on the browser
so I produced a version for Chrome
instead of a toolbar Chrome lets
developers produce plugins they call
extensions
and you can see that this extension here
really is a blatant copy of what Ping
did
now I wasn't entirely happy with it
um settings are typically easier to
remember most of the time but when
they're not it's really annoying that
they aren't synchronized across your
machines
um personas are what you call it when
you have a Facebook account for work and
one for home and you want to use
different credentials for them or you
have a shared machine at home and
everyone uses the same Netflix login
that would be one persona but each
person each person wants their own
Instagram credentials so each person
would have their own persona
now this version handled personas but
the code was way more complicated than I
was comfortable with
and the big problem for me personally
was that it only found the password
field about half the time
and I found autofill to be the most uh
user friendly feature of the whole thing
so I put it in the Chrome Store but only
available for testers
and some of them used it some for a
while I don't know that anybody else
used it for very long but I used it for
10 years for all my passwords
um we and then in late
2021 Google told developers that we'd
have to update our extensions
now at the time I was working for a
startup and it was in the process of
shutting down so I figured I'd take a
couple of weeks and and make the changes
and here I am talking to you over a year
later and I only got it in the Chrome
Store for testing in January of this
year
so the question is why did it take me so
long
um here's what the new version looks
like it's much better that's thanks to
Dale Schumacher but that wasn't the
reason for the delay
the original version used something
called Google called manifest2
which had a persistent background page
site password never stores your master
password
um but I could keep it in the process
running the background page and be sure
it was available whenever you needed to
calculate a password
that's not true for the new version that
has to use what Google calls manifest
three
there's no persistent background page
just a transient service worker that can
stop at any time and when it does stop
it loses its memory that meant I had to
find a different place to remember your
master password and it turns out there's
something called session storage that
has all the right properties
the second complication is that almost
anything you want to do with manifest3
involves async now I've done my share of
async programming it's not my favorite
but I can do it but this was the first
time I had converted a synchronous
program to async and let me just be kind
to myself and say I made more than my
share of mistakes
and then since I was out of work I
decided to fix the things I didn't like
about the earlier version
for reasons I'll explain later it took
me about six months to get to the point
where I could find the password field
and every one of the 120 plus sites that
I test with
I also spent a fair amount of time
trying to figure out how to synchronize
and how to handle PreSonus and then I
finally came upon my solution for those
two let Google do the heavy lifting
my trick is I store your settings in
bookmarks and that has a number of
advantages
there's no need for user accounts in
cloud storage the browser takes care of
the synchronization for me
the bookmarks also synchronize with your
mobile devices even without the
extension installed
each Persona automatically gets its own
bookline so I didn't have to deal with
that
you don't lose your settings if you have
to reinstall the extension I don't know
if you've experienced this with other
extensions but if you uninstall them
typically you lose all your store data
and have to reconstruct it if you
reinstall
and finally you can use different
browsers because you can import your
bookmarks to them
um I have to deal with one problem uh
Google allows you to have multiple
bookmarks with the same name
that's confusing for programs people
could usually figure it out but there is
a pretty simple solution
a site password itself will delete one
of we'll we'll delete the duplicates
automatically if they're identical and
we'll ask the user which one to use if
they're not
and then this feature called profiles
um Google profiles provides everything
needed to support her phone personas
so let me give you a little taste of
past with a site password and I can show
a demo later if if time permits
so the first time you visit a login page
after installing the extension you'll
see something like this page and the
password field says click psych password
so you click on the site password icon
that little thing that looks like a
calculator
and you see this form that you fill in
and now you fill in the form and you can
see there you've got your site password
starts with the letters t03x
right
and when you Mouse out
your user ID gets filled in and the
password field says click here for
password
you click and now you're ready to log in
now the best part is if you return to
this page
later on any machine that has the
extension installed and synchronizes
your bookmarks
all you have to do is click on the login
field uh to get to log in you don't have
to open the pop-up you don't have to
fill in anything else you just click and
you're ready to log in
now remember a piece of paper I
mentioned
um at the bottom here you can see a
button download site data and it creates
a file with a nicely formatted table of
your settings for each site
you can print it out and carry it in
your pocket
however if you store it in the cloud you
don't even have to type in your settings
you can copy The Bookmark from a link
stored in in that file
remember that um
site password started as an anti-fishing
toolbar
so it warns you if you might be at a
phishing site
if you open site password and try to
fill in a site name you'd used for a
different domain you get this big scary
warning you may not be able to read it
but what it's saying here is that the
domain name with a-l-l-a-m is not the
one where you set up the account that
one was Al Ada and you might be being
fished here and if you click on get me
to safety it will take you back to your
home page
but clicking on the red button says this
is not fishing this is just two
different domain names for the same
account
and it will now remember your settings
so you won't see this warning again for
that domain
and if you're at a friend's house well
there's a web page for that
um this would also be on your mobile
device where you can't install the
extension
so it's basically the same form and if
you have access to your bookmarks you
can just paste in the bookmark to get
all your settings
and in this case you can see that you've
got that same password
t03x and if you remember the settings
they'll be remembered only on this
device
um now site password has extensive
instructions and my hope is that no one
will ever read them
and I'll talk about that when I talk
about usability
um there may be times when you have to
provide your own password
um maybe you can't satisfy the password
rules
um that's never happened in my 10 years
of use and testing on over 300 sites but
there's a website called
dumbpasswordrules.com and there are
actually four five sites out of 300 some
odd that I I can't compute the password
for
um or maybe you've been given a password
and you're not allowed to change it
a site password will store this password
for you in the bookmark encrypted with
the calculated password for this site
and that means you can even retrieve
your calculated password from the
bookmarks
and that's what makes this a hybrid
password manager because its primary
function is to calculate passwords but
you can also use it to store them when
you have to
so let's talk about usability I I
mentioned earlier that that's a major
reason people give up on password
managers but usability isn't quite the
right thing we're interested in usable
security
and what that means is that no system
can be secure if users don't understand
the implications of their actions
Now that statement while true isn't very
helpful for designing a user experience
so I rely on Ping's 10 principles for a
secure ux and yes that's the same thing
now many of these don't apply to site
password but several of them do
make the easy way the secure way
once you've set up a site it's actually
easier to log in with site password than
it is to type even a simple password
that you use everywhere
so we got that one covered
explicit authorization so we're not
talking about authorizing somebody to do
something on your behalf but site
password won't insert your password
until you click on the password field
and that has two effects it avoids a
particular family of attacks but maybe
equally important it gives you control
over where your password goes
um site password isn't about granting
permissions that you might want to
revoke but you can easily forget the
settings for a site by deleting its
bookmark
and for expressiveness here it's it's
the password rules
um password rules at sites can get
pretty funky and I believe site password
is the only password calculator
expressive enough to cover nearly all of
those sites in the dumb password
rules.com
in addition I have my own guidelines
um I want the tools I build to be as
easy to use as a game you don't read the
instructions for Candy Crush on your
phone you just play with no worries that
you might break system break something
I also believe that a help button is a
crutch for developers I've actually
heard more than one say oh we'll just
explain that in the help rather than
trying to figure out how to make it
obvious what to do
you also want to encourage good
practices that's why psyc password has a
strength meter for your master password
and it will let you know if a site
password happens to be weak
um a readable font is important uh that
was a hard lesson hard-earned lesson for
me
um
I did follow that advice and uh it took
me three tries to log into Netflix on my
new smart TV because I got confused
between lowercase L and uppercase I
um and so I was careful about that this
time
users are often uncertain about what to
do next and so one hint you can give
them is to focus on the field they need
to fill in and it seems then they'll
just follow the moving cursor and go to
the correct place
and then there's a pet peeve of mine
um did you ever get a code that one of
these codes texted as a second Factor
and you sit there and you type it in and
when you look at the field there's
nothing there because the field wasn't
focused for you I absolutely hate that
so I try to do better than that
um I haven't been completely successful
there's still some things I'm not happy
with that placeholder click here for
password
um doesn't show up all the time there
are a few pages where I simply can't
figure out why it's not showing I spent
the better part of a week at one website
uh and I never did figure out why it
didn't I resorted to a tool tip but how
do you make it obvious to the user hold
your mouse over the password field for a
second or two that's how long it takes
for the tooltip to show up
um again I said you sometimes want to
forget the settings for a domain
you just re just uh Delete the bookmark
but how do you make that obvious I mean
you can put it in the help but I don't
want to do that
and then closing the pop-up this was an
odd problem
if I close the pop-up when it loses
Focus
you have to click twice to get your
password once to close the pop-up and
wants to insert the password yuck
if I close the pop-up when you Mouse out
it's too easy to do that accidentally
double yuck
so instead what I do is I wait three
quarters of a second before closing the
pop-up when you Mouse out and I keep it
open if you mouse back in before it
closes
I hope that's long enough that you get
your mouse back and short enough that
you don't have to click twice to get
your password I mean if you get your
mouse over to the password field within
that three quarters of a second and
click it'll just close the popper
um the second important factor for a
password manager is security
so let's talk about that
the situation on mobile devices devices
is really bad turns out you can build an
app that will find the password field if
it will fill in the password field of
another app and that's great
the problem is it's too easy to spoof
app identity so you might end up giving
away your password
and it turns out there's a similar
problem with webview on Android
the situation is so bad that one
password manager actually pulled their
app out of the App Store so I'm not
going to talk about mobile devices
anymore
I I believe all browsers these days have
a built-in password manager typically
they're not great of course they're far
better than not using one at all
and as far as I can tell they always
find the password field so you you don't
have to use the clipboard you don't want
to put your password on the clipboard
where any any other application running
on your machine can read it
um the big problem is that the articles
on this I read say that they're not as
secure as the Standalone password
managers
except for the fact that any password
manager
um you know any password manager that
asks you to provide passwords has a
usable security issue by making it too
easy to just keep using weaker reuse
passwords
um and also the password managers that
do generate passwords
um few of them take into account the
password rules for the site so there may
be a site where the random password
generator simply can't generate an
acceptable password for that site
now I wanted to get some experience with
this I I never used those so
um I set up the the Chrome browser a
couple of sites with the Chrome browser
and I like to say there are four things
a password password manager should never
do and chrome does four and a half of
them
um the first thing it does that isn't
good is it auto fills passwords without
any user action
that means your password can be stolen
if a bad guy can inject the password
field at any page in the domain of the
login page it could be an FAQ or a
contact contact us page a page that
nobody thinks has any security
implications
there's even an attack that only takes a
few minutes to steal all the passwords
your password manager is stored
um
there is a way that the browser can
block these attacks that isn't available
to extensions but I verified that the
Chrome browser doesn't do it
um
another way another thing I couldn't
figure out was how to tell the browser
about the funky password rules that my
power company cited simply did not
generate a legal password for that site
it allows you to encrypt your passwords
but that's not the default and if you do
you're going to get a big scary warning
seems odd that they want to scare you
away from encrypting your passwords
the browser will warn you if you've
created weak passwords
but only after you explicitly check it
doesn't tell you at the time you you put
them in to be managed
um it also assumes that any element of
type password holds a password now many
sites don't do that they they have other
things they they want don't want shown
on the screen and they only way to
replace it with dots is to put a uh call
it a pass type an input field of type
password but if they don't think it's a
password they might not give it as much
effort as they should in protecting it
now one thing interesting is that it
uses the same password for
smile.amazon.com and amazon.com which is
great
but it doesn't use the same password for
amazon.co.com.uk
um it turns out that this is a very hard
problem to know with two domain names or
for logging into the same account
now it could be that they're they're
checking the TLs certificate but I can't
be sure and Google doesn't make the TLs
certificate available to extensions so I
can't test it myself in my extension
um I think the minuses of using the
built-in password managers outweigh the
pluses so I'm not going to talk about
them further
um but getting a different strong
password for every site is just the
beginning of password manager security
I've already mentioned the problems with
autofill and we've seen that the
database is holding your passwords can
be can be stolen
but warning the user about we can use
reuse passwords is also important now
there's an example here there's o m m
thing
um there's a guy for his PhD thesis one
of the things he did was he had a
password manager generate 140 million
random passwords
and about a dozen of them were easy to
guess
for example the one shown here can be
guessed in about 10 seconds at a million
guesses per second
um so as I mentioned site password uh
has a strength meter so people will know
if they've got a strong master password
I don't enforce that but I'll let you
know if it's weak
um also your site password will be in a
noticeable color if if site password
should accidentally compute a weak one
um and that's why uh this the provided
site password I showed you earlier was
green that's used to indicate that it
was okay not weak but not great either
um I think your password manager should
warn you if you're at a possible
phishing site
but if you're using ones that store your
password you also have to be worried
about being fished for your password
manager password I mean what's to
prevent a malicious web page from
showing you a form that just looks just
like your password managers
um then I mentioned the problem of
amazon.com and amazon.co.uk
it sure would be nice if you could tell
Louis we're both for logging in the same
account
I spent some time trying to figure it
out
and I failed
um there is a very nice piece of code
it's very highly upvoted on stack
overflow
and it tells you that you should use the
same password for mail.google.com and
maps.google.com that's good
unfortunately it also says you should
use that same password for
google.evil.com which is probably not a
good idea
accessibility features are interesting
um for example you don't want a screen
reader to say your passwords out loud
when you're in a public place
the other issue is the size of the code
some of the open source tools I looked
at are gigantic one's over a quarter
million lines of code
site password is just about one percent
of that
and of course that means I only produced
about 10 lines of code per workday and I
don't know how happy you'd be if I was
part of your team when you were in a
rush
I also think it's a big problem when
login Pages rely on jQuery
uh don't get me wrong I love jQuery I
think it reads your mind it does what
you want not what you said but it is a
big dependency and with all the issues
we have on supply chain attacks I don't
think it should be on a security
critical page
reticular site password is
self-contained it never talks on the
network once it's been loaded
um but
worst of all is a password manager that
doesn't convey trust that doesn't give
you the warm fuzzies I mentioned because
then you'll give up using password
managers and that's the worst of all
so how does uh site password do on the
security
well I think I've done a pretty good job
you have to click on the password field
and that blocks an entire family of
attacks
I only register the callback for putting
the password in the field when you click
on visible password fields and that will
defeat some click jacking attacks that's
where they put an invisible field on the
on the page and you think you're
clicking on something underneath it but
you're actually clicking on the the
thing there I won't be putting your
password into that field
I use the iframe domain name when I look
up the settings to use for calculating
the password
um that's the right thing to do because
you wouldn't want an ad on a page to you
know get your New York Times password
just because it was on the same page as
nytimes.com
um but that also means that users will
see a bookmark with a strange domain
name I don't know quite what to do about
that
um it used to be that that determining
if a password was strong was difficult
there was a lot of disagreement about
what that meant but Dropbox produced
this very nice tool which is the one I
use
um it's so good site password
distribution without it is less than 100
kilobytes but that tool was so good that
I'm using it even though the
distribution is now just over a megabyte
there's also the case that attackers
produce what are called rainbow tables
they will pre-compute the hash of all
possible passwords up to some size 8 12
even 14 characters I mean terabytes of
data in these tables and then if they
get the hash of a password it's just the
lookup to find the actual password
um but you know that might work for a
site password because the the site
itself doesn't add what's called salt
but your master password is safe from
that because it's combined with your
user and site names to produce your site
password
and of course I've mentioned it's not
not a good idea to leave a password on
the clipboard any longer than necessary
so site password lets you know if you
might have done that
there are places where I uh made
compromises in the interest abusability
so for example I put things in
unencrypted bookmarks now bookmarks are
very well protected from code running on
web pages but not from now on your
machine
they're just stored in a file on your
of course if you've got malware on your
machine you've got bigger problems than
losing your settings
and Google has them in the in the Google
Cloud for the synchronization but if
Google gets hacked well Life as We Know
It Ends so I'm not going to worry about
that
I chose to make the site password
visible by default watching a change as
you type gives you a sense of how
uncorrelated your passwords are
and besides you rarely have to open the
pop-up it's just to set up a new site or
enter your master password at the start
of a browser session or on the rare
cases when you have to put it on the
clipboard
and I originally 12 so it's a 12
character site password because back
when the first time I did this too many
sites wouldn't take longer ones that's
less of a problem now but there are
still some that require that size or
shorting
then there's the ugly
there's a serious attack against your
master password
um it's no worse than against the stolen
password database but it is there
it turns out there are two kinds of
guessing attacks against passwords
in an online attack the bad guy goes to
to a bank login page enters your user ID
and starts guessing passwords
that's about all an attacker who gets
just your bookmarks can do they know
where you log in and what your user ID
is but no clue about your site or master
password
this attack is slow and it's easily
detected so we don't have to worry about
that
offline attacks are more serious so if
the attacker steals a password database
which stores the hashes of users
passwords and starts guessing that can
be fast and undetectable
and that attack is still there with site
password but it works differently
say that you create an account at a
rogue site
the bad guy now knows your user ID and
site password and can probably guess
your nickname for the site and now he
starts guessing Master passwords
now you can't eliminate that threat with
site password but you can mitigate it
with a strong master password
according to that Dropbox tool it would
take three days to guess a 12 character
password and a million guesses per
second
it would take centuries if you use 15
characters
site password also increases the work
needed for a guess by hashing a hundred
times before showing a site password
that means that a million guesses per
second it would take almost a year to
guess even a 12 character master
password
but then there's a mitigation that's not
available for the managers that's that
store your passwords you can use
different Master passwords for different
uses one for Banking and health and
other for subscriptions and a third one
for sketchy sites use that third one at
that Rogue site your money is still safe
now one of the things I missed from not
going to the office is hearing other
people's War Stories the crazy stuff
they ran into and how they dealt with it
um I hope you enjoy mine
um websites do some really weird
um we'll call it stuff
um as I said it took me six months to
find the password fields on all of my
test sites
um so here I'll tell you what some of
those issues were so it's quite common
to put a password field in an iframe and
that was the most common reason the
earlier version didn't find the password
field
fixing that got me from 50 or so of my
test sites to over 80.
um several sites build the page when you
load the URL if you do a view Source
you're only going to see a few lines of
HTML
fortunately uh there's something in
JavaScript called a mutation Observer
that lets you know when the web page is
changed and so doing that got me 20 more
sites
the rest of these changes got me a
couple each
sites create the password field as a
normal text field and later on change
the input type to password
unfortunately that doesn't count as a
mutation
so I had to add special code
um Dropbox I don't know if they still do
I forgot to check for this this talk
um used to have six password fields on
the page with only one of them visible
when you were logging in uh and it turns
out that determining visibility is quite
tricky and I'm going to show you in a
moment
um there are sites two of my test sites
actually add CSS at runtime
that takes an invisible password field
and makes it visible
and that too doesn't count as a mutation
so I had to write more special code
and then several sites don't make the
password visible until after you fill in
your user ID which means I can't fill it
in for you but once you do I've been
able to find the password field every
time
more crazy stuff uh one site actually
changes the look of the login form
depending on
the URL you used to get there and that
required even more special code
um one site puts the login form in
something called a shadow root I bet you
don't know what that is I'd never heard
of it
it was designed to completely
isolate a document inside the main
document
and that's a great idea except I've been
told by someone who knows that the
design is so flawed that it's not
particularly useful but did require more
special code
and then there's the bank
that clears the username and password
field two seconds after I fill them in
now if I type them in but if they're
Auto filled by site password I have no
idea what that's for and I couldn't even
figure out where in their code they were
doing it even though I single step
through thousands of lines of code the
workaround more special code
and finally I uh I loaded up the website
site password.info for testing and the
password field said click psych password
which I found annoying so I had to add a
special case for that URL
um finding out if an element is visible
is quite a challenge there is something
called window.computed style that gets
it right every time except when it
doesn't
when it doesn't you have to go look at
something called the offset parent
um
turned out it wasn't quite working for
me and I couldn't figure out why turned
out that that testing green
was on the documentation page but I only
saw it when I accidentally scrolled the
page it was just off the piece of code
that I was looking at that was two days
down the drain out of six months
um and then there are many ways to make
a field invisible but a common one is to
set the opacity to zero or a very small
value
there is a test
element.style.opacity but if the opacity
is zero the field is still reported as
visible
now this one's an easy one since there's
no good reason to change the visibility
of a login
for having found the password field how
do you find the user ID field you notice
I I fill in the user ID for you uh what
I found is most password managers use
the simple heuristic of choosing the
element immediately input element
immediately preceding the password on it
um there are often intervening input
Fields uh but they're almost never
visible
except for one of my 120 plus sites
in that one I don't get the username in
the right field at least one other
password manager gets it get get its
gets it right and my understand my my
understanding is they actually have a
special case just for that one website I
I just can't bring myself to do that
um and then there's the really crazy
stuff
things you might expect from your corner
bagel shop who hired the neighbors
teenager to build their website but
these are major Banks and Retail
companies
um as we've seen there can be multiple
name domain names
for the login page on One bank has
securone.bank.com
securo2.bank.com I've seen
securo7.bank.com each one of those is
going to show up as a fishing warning
the first time you encounter a new one
because I can't be sure that it's really
Bank one.com is the right is is the
actual site
um my health insurance company is
training me to be fished
um they have me when I click the button
to log in they take me to a completely
different website
um
there's a rule in HTML that any element
can be given an ID that's how you say I
want to associate this piece of code
when you click that that element
and almost anything will do the Only
Rule is that IDs have to be unique or oh
how will break loose well good rule
don't count on it
one major store uses the same ID for the
username and password elements
which means I had to spend a day going
back and changing my code because I was
using the ID to track track them
um companies also work really hard to
improve the performance of their web
pages but you never know it by looking
at the developers console there's often
a gazillionaires a particularly
egregious example took 30 seconds for
the page to finish loading which meant
site password couldn't show your
username for that long
and of course your first reaction is
there's something wrong with site
password
the cause turned out to be four failed
gets which were done sequentially each
one timing out after seven and a half
seconds
um I I went back to show to to show
someone this problem and but they've
changed how they do the login so that's
no longer a problem but I still have to
have code in my in my distribution to
deal with that case so how bad is all of
this craziness
one password manager has special cases
for over 200 sites and I guess they got
people tracking uh those sites in case
they change what how they do things
all right time to wrap up
the future work I'd love to do user
studies but that's really hard for
someone working alone so I'm asking for
your help you're willing try it out and
give me your feedback a Security review
would be nice but paying for one is
certainly out of my price range unless
somebody wants to volunteer
site password now works on all the major
browsers Safari Firefox and most
chromium browsers you know Brave Edge
Opera but I need to do a lot more
testing on them and I'm keeping my eye
on mobile but I won't be building a site
password app until those security issues
I talked about get fixed
um here's where I got most of my
information I don't bother copying them
down you can get them from from that
GitHub site
um
and um you know pings tens principles
that's a paper worth reading anything
ping writes is worth reading it really
has interesting ideas on rights quite
well the OSH thesis is absolutely
amazingly comprehensive and that the
paper provides a good summary
so takeaways use a password manager
can't stress that enough my son uses the
one built into Chrome and in spite of
all the problems I pointed out I haven't
told them not to use it out of fear he
won't use a password manager at all
some autofill without user action turn
that off or be very careful about using
public Wi-Fi
if you find a replacement if you if you
find a replacement use that tool
um be ready in case they raise their
prices too much for you or go out of
business
and make sure you use strong passwords
even if the manager lets you use weak
ones
or use cite password and be in control
and that's it thanks I'll take questions
now
any questions
it was a great talk now thank you
I think that the um
I think it'll be a popular YouTube
uh reading from uh from the thing
because uh we'll May modify the titles
just a little bit to make it more
uh more of a how-to okay yeah and I
think that I think it's really it's very
nice uh nice Gathering of things
yeah thank you thank you well if anybody
wants to volunteer you can contact me at
Allen H carp gmail.com
and I'm looking for testers
there have been people who wanted to uh
do uh sites without passwords and do
Biometrics uh how how what's your
feeling on this I I think it's wonderful
the problem is can the electronic signal
that represents the biometric be
replicated and captured by Pat geisen
um that's the problem
um Mark Stigler
produced uh assist the you know system
where when you create your capture given
a bookmark you bookmark that and Scott
and I'm guessable you are element
and so all you have to do is click on
your bookmark to log in
the problem there is you can't log in
from a friend's house if you don't have
your bookmarks
so unless you distribute it to all
people at all times yeah right so that
you don't want to do that for if you
wanted that you would be using passwords
in the first place that's true
all right so you know there was a an IBM
in the 80s there was a
discussion about what what the company
should the company do something
company-wide about passwords and so they
got together a group of smart people who
decided that they wouldn't be using
passwords for very long anyway so it
wasn't worth the effort
[Music]
when I when I looked at the um
the Android stuff and you know they have
my phone has a sensor on the back
you know and it turns out that it's it
it's very useful that it's it's a good
two two Factor authenticator and so
forth and so on but it's not very good
compared to maybe four or five letters
in sequence on a typing well you know a
lot of it comes down to uh usability
um you know there's the gag about why is
mommy crying and the answer is
two-factor Authentication
okay
so
um yeah so you know
it's got to be usable by Ordinary People
who have more interesting things to do
than worry about computer security well
there's a wonderful paper about how to
uh how do you uh
phones which uh you use for two-factor
authentication how you can you can spoof
them it's not very difficult well
um there are so you know if it's the
kind of code where you know the web page
says we've just texted you a code type
it into this webpage that's pretty easy
for a man in the middle to defeat
the ones that use a back chin where they
put up a QR code on the page you scan it
with the phone and the phone contacts
the server by a different Channel those
are much harder for attackers to get
into
yeah
yeah but you know what you have to make
assumptions about what physical devices
people have I mean the uh the Fido Keys
the Yuba Keys that's a wonderful second
factor I use mine a lot
hey yo thank you very much it looks like
we don't have any comments and uh uh
that I think is the definition of a
really good talk thank you that's really
really great I enjoyed it thank you all
right good talking to you bye goodbye